I mean you can see the guy's eyes in
there it means something to guys and I
means you got guys who care about what
they're doing guys who care about each
other and uh
know very young team got a got a very
bright future so uh you know got to take
this in stride remember this feeling and
you know let if you listen and they
offseason Jimmy Garoppolo 49ers
quarterback after the Super Bowl loss
the Kansas City Chiefs and look the
future is bright for the 49ers but the
target is as big for them Chris yes it
is for the Chiefs they get the same
target they just don't get the rings
rise everybody's going to be gunning for
the 49ers next year and this talk of
Jimmy Garoppolo being the weak link is
not going going to go away no no it's
not gonna go away
we know that yeah that's gonna be part
of the conversation you know but again
he went thirteen and three and was up
twenty to ten with six minutes left in
the fourth quarter of the Super Bowl and
he was 3 for 11 in the fourth quarter I
get that now you know hey two or three
of those passes were batted down you
know by Chris Joe's he can't block guys
and do it it just happens sometimes okay
and yes I know he didn't win the game
Mike I get it he fell victim to a guy
that we've all are sitting here going
this guy might be the greatest player
we've ever seen so it's not like you
know this crazy crazy thing damn yeah
hey Chris Chris let me say something let
me say something because I want to go
back to yesterday I uh I I didn't push
you as hard as I should have you win a
and I need to be fair we're we're
friends so we can speak candidly okay of
course your your tattoo buddy screwed it
up he really did and I know you're gonna
disagree with me
but because of but because of that you
just yeah the reason I'm saying this
because Patrick mahomes is Patrick
mahomes
right you keep that guy off the field
when you've got the ball and here's what
I'm gonna focus on up three with six
minutes and change and you just gained
five yards on first down and it's second
and five you do not throw on the next
play and I get it well hey Chris Jones
made a play but that's one of the risks
you assume when you call a pass play
that's one of the things that can happen
the ball can get batted down at the line
of scrimmage okay when you
run the boat when you run the ball what
happens you're gonna take 40 seconds off
the clock
and maybe you're gonna have third and -
mmm maybe you can extract a dress listen
I got no problem with that fine if you
want to say that that's fine but then I
can go meat grinder running game run the
ball yeah sure they weren't running in
the ball that great in so that that's
the other issue too you know okay so
what what what if they ran the ball for
no yards they're gonna have to throw the
ball the next down anyways like like
okay yes did you have two more seconds
off the clock
you're sure and I you know again listen
I understand it I understand the thought
of it all I'm trying to say it wasn't
egregiously wrong and he dialed up a
play that was quite honestly perfect the
guy was wide open you know Chris Jones
just said he's a really good he's get
paid he gets paid money too he's
actually a part of the risk she was soon
yeah that's the thing when you call a
past play there's a chance that's good I
so the only rule okay but he's going for
the win if he lost the game everybody
would be going you gotta be aggressive
everybody's getting on him for the end
of the second quarter for not being
aggressive there but what was he doing
Mike he was keeping the greatest
football player on the field all types
different times like this okay
but either way but now it's 20 to 17 and
he just saw mahomes kind to get fire on
fire huh recent history has kind of
showed us when he goes on drives like
that damn you know what he goes on fire
so he was trying to put him away that
way again I'm not sitting here telling
you I would have definitely thrown the
ball I'm just saying I don't think it's
the most egregious error ever I think
people are piling on my buddy Kyle
Shanahan because they can just find a
common link between 28:3 and this I
haven't mentioned 28 three people
meat-grinder running game right that
that you'd gain five yards on first down
give give yourself a short third down
where you could run it or pass it I mean
go put some doubt in the chick get them
thinking oh here goes the clock I mean
there is no worse feeling when you're
trying to come from behind then seeing
the clock tick and tick and take and
take and they're in a damn thing you can
do about it and if they could have slid
into that same running mode that we saw
against the Vikings of the Packers we'd
be talking about but they make
oh that's not fair they weren't the
Chiefs that they were in the same
problem the drive before it it was first
intend and they ran for one yard and
then it'll end up being they ran for
five to say five not ii enough okay but
he this is why he changed and he dialed
up an awesome play i think you know the
guy made a play there's that he threw it
he designed a play for it got to be open
four feet in front of Jimmy Garoppolo
Chris Jones made him play his way
football is we'll be right back was this
jerk Florio
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports